[Music]
[Applause]
hello it is a cloudy but hot day here at
the Guiana Space Centre where you are
joining us live for the launch of the
next four satellites in the o3b
constellation for SES I'm in the Mission
Control Centre I'm Katie as well and I'm
joined by Luce fabricate from area and
space and loose it's a big welcome to
everybody
hello everybody welcome welcome here -
our customers are guests in the French
Space Center and the welcome to
everybody watching us on internet now we
are flying on board a Soyuz launcher
today it's made of four stages we call
those stages four sections the first
three stages are the propelled part of
the flight getting us away from our
planet and then if we take a look at the
top of the launch vehicle inside there
you can see our satellites and they are
the 403b
satellites for SES networks all tucked
up inside the launcher nice and cool
inside there with the air-conditioning
systems there in first class with their
seatbelts on now loose before we talk to
you let me just tell everybody your job
title loose is the executive vice
president of missions operations and
purchasing here at Orion space and
you're in charge of the flight
Directorate today
loose just tell us a little bit more
about our mission today so today we are
launching four satellites as you said
telecom satellites though they are they
are not going to the geostationary orbit
which is the usual orbit for telecom
satellites they are going to what we
call the medium Earth orbit at 8,000
kilometers from Earth so four times
closer than the geostationary orbit
which allows a low latency connectivity
so how has the countdown been
progressing so we have started in the
night here the operations they are they
are going very smoothly and we have
removed already suburban country the
the launch maker is getting ready to
lift off and we we need an additional
check on the ground so we are going to
target launch at two two hours and three
minutes local time - yes rather than -
as three minutes past - the time pass -
okay exactly and and so we are ready and
all the computers on board and and the
in the operators are currently preparing
the launch vehicle for the flight so
we've reset our launch time for 33
minutes later exactly we will take 33
minutes and we will we can target 33
minutes later without any difficulty so
we will take time for additional check
and then go go for launch in in 33
minutes later now lose we it's going to
take us it's going to be a long mission
today actually because it's going to
take us over 2 hours I think roughly
about 2 hours and 20 minutes to deliver
our first set of satellites can you
explain what's gonna happen so after
liftoff there will be the face of what
we call the 3 stage the 3 lower stage of
the Soyuz then they will separate the
upper stage and frigate upper stage the
frigate upper stage will have to boost
of its main engine above Atlantic Ocean
and Africa and we will follow this boost
from from our ground stations then it
there will have a long ballistic phase
of 1 hour and 20 minutes and after this
ballistic phase when we'll be above the
Pacific Ocean and at a high altitude at
that time there will be a new boost of
the main engine before the separation of
the two first satellites and then 20
minutes later the two last satellites so
the whole mission as you said will last
for two and to two hours and 20 minutes
you thank you very much indeed for
joining us here on the floor you can now
go back to your place so the flight
director it back there thank you loose
news fabricate ladies and gentlemen now
as loose has just explained to us so
loose is actually now taking up her
position behind me is what we call the
fishbowl this is
reinforced glass and the operational
teams are working here and she taking is
taking up her position on the flight
Directorate now as loose just explained
like in the option today which is an
option on this particular flight to
launch 33 minutes later than the planned
launch time so we're going to be
launching at two oh three three minutes
past two that's here local time so
Universal time that's two three four
five five minutes past three minutes
past five it's three minutes past 6:00 I
believe so
we're going to take a little break now
in our program if this is giving
everybody a chance to sort of take a
breather and we'll be coming back to you
eleven minutes before the launch the new
launch time so we'll see you back here
then
welcome back you are with us we are live
at the Guiana Space Centre here on the
edge of the Amazon rainforest and we are
here for the launch of the next
a to the video at own shop Oh as
imaginative a second top the Builder
seconds final no sir
[Music]
hello
hello I'm David Franken and I'm the
mission director for the vs 22 launch
campaign I'm responsible for the overall
organization of the satellite campaign
the interfacing with the launch vehicle
and the final chronology we are now in
the final phase of this twenty second
service launch campaign from Google for
the fifth batch of ultra V satellites
the satellite campaign started on the
2nd of February when the four satellites
arrived at the félix eboué Airport in an
ilyushin aircraft the satellites and
allied equipments were transported to
the s5c facilities the same day in the
s5c the satellites were unpacked one by
one and were installed in the cleanroom
after which they were subjected to an
extensive electrical check out also the
propulsion system was carefully verified
before starting the fuelling
preparations on the 19th of February the
first satellite was transferred to the
s5b fuelling home after finalization of
the fuelling preparations the satellite
was filled with hydrazine then
pressurized and finally integrated on a
dedicated dispenser the next three
satellites followed the same process in
the following weeks the stack with the
four satellites was finalized on the
14th of March
so like offenses on this the US 2010
launch campaign I'm the Cohen did not
launch site head of operations I leave
did launch campaign operational team
working on the ground to make both the
vulture and the ground installations
ready for launch vs 22 launcher campaign
started on February 6 with the arrival
of the frigate at the stage in the MOOC
building during the first three weeks of
the launch campaign forget underwent by
various electrical and climatic checks
after those three weeks frigate was
transferred to FC fulfilling building
this is on the slaves launch complex and
parallel the assembly operations of the
tricky stage were carried out to the
make building market so uses assemble a
little horizontally the first we put
together the two hearts are the central
body then we assembled around the
central hold on the four boosters these
gifts are uses characteristic highly
aerodynamic silhouette finally we
assembled the third stage on the central
core it easily spoken for thanks to the
lattice after assembly the try stage
underwent various electrical animatic
functional tests but after fitting
operations in the F key ruling he forget
was transferred to the s-3b building 12
kilometers from the Soyuz launch pad
after a standby phase of one week the
stack was transported to the s3p
building in a CC o3 container on the
26th of march the dispenser wait for
satellites was integrated onto the
Fagin's the day after the splines
performed their internal dress rehearsal
and final functional verifications
before the encapsulation the fairing was
integrated on the 28th of March which
completed the upper composites
she won't do minus three is the first of
the four days of the campaign phase but
the try stage and the upper composite
are transferred to the launch pad
dual mata early in the morning the try
stage is rolled out to the launch ozone
then put in vertical position thanks to
the erector railcar in the afternoon the
upper composite reaches the Soyuz launch
zone after trip of around an hour and a
half from the s3b in early evening the
upper come visit is hoisted into the
mobile country 27 meters high to be
assembled on the try stage with the
Soyuz launch are completely integrated
the different teams performs the general
dress rehearsal the launch readiness
review has been held yesterday and a
green light has been given to start the
final chronology we are go for launch
the edges on bedico show
a to do attention Pumas in minute top as
a woman in minute
like ajumma Kassadin a to the video
otoscope individual a secondary marginal
sir top human vessel on like asthma
became a de Mestre attached to deliver
so pretty confident this nerve we said
this say what the college events when do
[Music]
the professional
the power the parameter about tsunami
knew
the profession a nominal
technology on the booster
to the pyramid tsunami no
to tell you how loud that is he's
telling us the launch vehicle is stable
and also of course friction because if
you look at the bottom right-hand side
of this left-hand side of the screen we
are now 120 kilometers above Earth until
now we've been flying through the dense
part of the atmosphere but we no longer
have friction because we are in space so
we can jettison offensive work and
that's now being confirmed we have
jettisoned the fairing and we can see
our satellites for the first time the
403b satellites at the front attached to
their special dispenser and in the
middle can you see a gap between the
third stage and the second stage
well that's there on purpose with the
lattice area that's because Soyuz uses
what's called a hot stage technique it's
so it switches on the engine of the
third stage well the second stage is
still burning and that allows the
evacuation
so and we have confirmation there that
we've now separated sorry oh the block a
and we have jettisoned the rear section
so we are now burning the third stage
and our flight path you can see it there
we're traveling along the equator so
we've lifted off from the pad the Gallio
is the tracking station here at the
Guiana Space Centre and the next one to
pick us up will be the natal tracking
station these computer-generated images
are a simulation of what the experts
have planned and it's what they've
calculated is happening to the launcher
and the satellites the proportions
nominal normal so basically what they do
is they they take all the information
all the data and all the schedule of
events that is based on extremely
accurate predictions dedicated I didn't
get a chance to read it if he puts it up
again I shall translate it for you they
put all of that into the computer which
then generates these images for us and
allows us to visualize what's happening
up there in space because of course what
happens in space is something we can't
actually see with our own cameras we
lifted off from the pad 6 minutes and 52
seconds ago it was a spectacular launch
the 403b satellites lifted off in style
in their first-class compartment with
their seatbelts on onboard the 22nd
launched Soyuz launch vehicle to liftoff
from this part here the dedicated pad at
the Guiana Space Centre we are now
entered into the tracking zone of the
natal ground station the range
operations manager has just confirmed
that natal have picked us up so you can
see it there it's on the northeastern
coast of Brazil the tracking stations
often known as downrange
stations the range is the space port but
also all the other associated buildings
across the planet which pick up the
signal as we this allows us to track
what the launch is doing in real time
but also to check afterwards make an
evaluation and saw use the saw use the
flight data from the rocket does go via
Moscow first to be validated sometimes
it can take a little time for us to get
immuno confirmations but we're seeing
key moments happening at the scheduled
time telemetry is also known as
telematics telemetry of course being the
the name for the process of sending the
signal to the tracking stations we use
telemetry and it's a technology which
allows measurements to be taken from far
away it actually comes from the Greek
telly
which means remote like television or
telemedicine medicine from a distance
and Metron meaning measure so measure
and from a distance see it in a lot of
industries oil and gas for example
medicine healthcare mining so this is
the scheduled separation now of the
third stage and that's what it looks
like up there is your forget and we have
that confirmed by the range operations
manager we have separated the third
stage and we are getting close now to
the next phase of the journey where the
upper stage will take the wheel its
preparing
preparing to switch its engine on this
is called the pre burn phase giving a
quick burst of acceleration you can't
really see it but it's pushing the
fluids back into the tanks and that's to
make sure that there is enough
propellant to ignite the engine properly
it's a bit like when you press the
accelerator in the car and you suddenly
speed up and you get pushed back against
the seat this is the scheduled time then
for frigate to switch its engine on for
the first burn its job being to deliver
our satellites to their drop-off point
in space so we're going to find out more
now about our four satellites
I'm Veronique Rozelle and I'm the
program director of a science base for
this program my work mainly consists in
interfacing with our customer SES for
all subjects linked to technical matters
but also contractual communication
financial insurance and legal aspects
our job is to respond at best at our
customers requests this launch come
after the fall first Soyuz STB launches
dedicated to the deployment of for 3b
constellation successfully performed
also from French Guiana since June 2013
as someone on the specific dispenser
under the fairing the four new ka-band
satellites with John ACS existing
constellation of sixteen Meo satellites
orbiting at approximately 8,000
kilometers from Earth the in orbit
service provides an enhanced internet
connectivity with five equivalent
affirmance and high capacity for data
solution management's this for all three
B satellites have been manufactured by
Telus arena space as the previous ones
and now I would like to introduce you
with Tim Gore the OSI bf5 deputy mission
director Tim could you provide us with
some explanation on those Phoebus
satellites and the mission of this
constellation sure as he only
operationally and commercially proven
non geostationary satellite orbit
broadband constellation the o3b meal
system has been successful since its
first launch in 2013 the unique high
throughput all three B constellation has
been imperative and helping SGS achieve
its bold vision of changing lives by
connecting people it's proven impact and
we felt by customers operating in nearly
50 countries today ok 8,000 kilometers
from the earth the o3b meal
constellation is home low-latency
5 light connectivity provided for fixed
data mobility and government markets
seamless capability of the constellation
means of additional satellites will
enhance coverage across the globe and
enable SES networks to provide greater
service availability and reliability to
cater to the increasing demand for
networked applications in the government
telecom
Wow maritime and energy markets the four
satellites launched today are the last
batch of all three satellites to join
our first generation meal fleet it also
marks the transition to our next gen
Neill system the highly anticipated
launch of o3b mPower in 2021 and once
the service all three M Powell will
transform the market yet again thank you
for this explanation steam words yes
again slightly before the first
spacecraft separation great looking
forward to it and now I would like to
take the opportunity to thank Telus
Iranian space for the great job for the
excellent work during the complete
program and let me also express my
gratitude of course to our renowned
customer SES for their continuous
confidence for more than 30 years indeed
and during that film they were scheduled
to pick up the signal at the tracking
station in Ascension Island which is a
volcanic outcrop in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean we're heading out across
the pond towards the west coast of
Africa yes yes team's here smiling and
Ascension Island used to be a stopover
during the early days of commercial
airlines indeed NASA had a
communications dish there that was
during the space race in the mid 1900s I
think that it was used to track the
Apollo's though it's been played an
important role over the years so the
frigate upper stage was scheduled to
switch its engine off and once an engine
is switched off the next phase of a
flight starts it's called
the ballistic phase ballistic means
traveling without propulsion so a
spacecraft or a launcher has to be
traveling high enough and fast enough to
cruise without the engine and that saves
on propellant
and helps to optimize the conditions of
the flight oh three be switched on
services in September 2014
and since then the constellation has
grown from strength to strength
[Music]
in 2009 SES is investment in the oh
three B medium Earth orbit or mio
constellation marked a new venture into
non geostationary satellites of this
pioneering move disrupted the
traditional satellite market and
established SES is vision to connect the
underserved on a global scale vision
became reality in 2013 with the first
Meo satellites launched and here today
in the jungles of French Guiana we
launched out Phoebe for the last few
years our life at o3b has been about
building stuff from today that all
changes from today our business is about
our customers company and we aspire to
be the team that you choose to work with
ever since the o3b constellation has
delivered against its bold vision today
the o3b system delivers to nearly 50
countries around the world and now if
you go to the DRC or to South Sudan or
to Chad or to the Amazon or large parts
of the Pacific what you see is people
connected to the internet connected to
the world's marketplace and the world's
universities connected to the world's
health systems we've had a dramatic
impact
[Music]
from minister in space yesterday by the
comment that I think was most important
thing this happened in page a in the
years since independence in 1975 we had
the responsibility to ensure that we
were able to provide seamless
connectivity to the visiting leaders the
media we basically needed a turnkey
solution supply install Commission then
support through Ipek and we got all of
those things promised a yes nature
diesel ADSL on say Robert Rios issue at
YC perform a on the connection little
part to do satisfied not to not move
Laura set station create a new original
novel and service quality sensor money
repo shop avvocato a b c 2 t don't
analogy the kenai to permit should be
shifted the platform governments would
neva television gracias a la solution
implement a mode they ought resume with
intelligent be our in that all Zuzu's
warius what law hey insulate ova Nikita
client appointment ever the CIA they
were high out of the diamond you can
believe anything in Tarragona SES as
partners they covered 99 percent of the
world's population with their satellite
constellations
all in service to the guests because
it's all about the guest experience the
o 3p system has already transformed our
customers businesses and that end users
lives this launch is a really exciting
and important one for us at SES and also
one that marks a very important point in
the o3b journey
it marks the last four satellites in the
first generation system of o3v
but it's also a massive introduction to
the next generation o to be in power
where we've taken the proven aspects of
o3v them we've scaled it ridiculously to
bring that same capability affordable
plentiful bandwidth
any place on the planet with o3b empower
we are now taking this proven model to
the next level
[Music]
and today's 403b satellites will mean
that aryan space will have launched 61
satellites for their friends at SES so
we've had several confirmations the
range operations manager confirmed we
had indeed switched off our engine on
the frigate upper stage and we also
picked up the signal at the tracking
station in Libreville which is in Gabon
on the west coast of Africa western
central Africa in fact apparently in the
port's
port city on the Como River which is
near the Gulf of Guinea and I believe
that the tracking station has been there
since 1994
apparently the German space agency set
up there
so the o3b satellites have clever
technology
in an empowered world you are free
free to bring loved ones along on
distant voyages
[Music]
observe
protect
and enable rapid response with
life-saving communication streamline
operations in real-time
no matter the location
bring cloud services and content to new
uncharted markets
with global coverage and load agency
performance
you're free to follow opportunities
anywhere oh three PM power engineering
freedom the Redeemer after that you have
already many much figure so the range
operations marriage is telling us that
everything's going normally we have now
started the next maneuver frigate is
getting ready to switch its engine back
on again so this is pre burn number two
and it will be giving another burst of
acceleration it uses small